[Musique]
oui tout a commencé à 14 heures les
services de la préfecture de police ont
posé des barrières pour interdire
l'accès des trois artères commerçantes
la rue du faubourg saint-honoré seul de
la chaussée d'antin et la rue de la
gaîté ces rues sont donc exclusivement
réservé aux piétons et jusqu'à 20h elles
seront encore le 19 le 24 veille de noël
et enfin les 26 et 31 décembre
pendant ces quatre jours le régime de
stationnement réglementé de la zone
bleue sera appliquée toute la journée
place de la concorde et avenue gabriel
en outre pour aider les gens qui
viennent faire leurs courses avant les
vacances et bien deux stations de taxis
sont créés provisoirement la première
avenue de marigny c'est-à-dire à l'angle
de la rue du faubourg saint-honoré la
seconde revue boissy d'anglas ce
également à l'angle de la rue du
faubourg saint-honoré
il y a bien entendu le métro et puis les
lignes d'autobus même galets vous êtes
la présidente des commerçants de cette
rue de la gaîté oui fait que les
avantages pour nous c'est quelque chose
de très important parce que justement ça
va permettre ou
consommateurs d
de venir nous voir que l'on qu'on pourra
justement vendre les jaunes beaucoup
plus une manière autre qu'avance caron
une femme qui a agressé sa voiture
absolument pas stationner
si alors les oui oui pelops tout le
monde repartait et on avait des gros
camions qui se plaçait devant nos
vitrines donc ce n'était pas la peine de
faire des vitrines très jolie parce
qu'on les voyait pas alors je pense que
pour nous il ça doit être un succès
mais damas pour y savourer cette
promenade en plein milieu de la rue du
faubourg saint-honoré
s'ils ne me fera pas ça
je continue en faites votre shopping
pour noël oui c'est de faire
[Musique]
actuellement nombre l automobile presse
à gap
gêné par le nsa depuis vous avez
certains 15,8 où on réussissait à
descendre l'avenue de la gomera par
exemple sans avoir de stand avant de
devenir la compagne de keller qui
convient oui mais elle a marqué l'arrêt
janvier c'est aujourd'hui de mesurer son
est ce que cela est un début cela va
créer un précédent j'espère bien
j'espère bien mais ça les moindres à des
talibans dans l'est parisien
la vosgienne
est ce que pensait que les parisiens
vont apprécier oh je fais j'espère les
commerçants les commerçants sont
inquiets pourquoi les gens ont peur que
les parisiens pris des gants de mobiles
m'inquiète plus dans leur magasin et moi
je prétends le tout faire brahim sans
qu'une fois à pied on a envie de
s'arrêter dans tous les magasins pour
lui d'aller dans un seul jeu va-t-il se
passer
[Musique]